um welcome to session three of
understanding anger 2.0 this is an
online course that meets monthly and I
do a little presentation about the topic
thinker text that we are looking into
that contain some insights about the
emotion of anger and then we do some
back and forth chat for those who are
enrolled in the class uh answering
questions comments and then after we
finish up with that typically we go on
to everybody being on camera and have a
little conversation so today we are
following up with our session that we
did last time about Plato in particular
this time we're getting to we could say
the real meet texts before we looked at
people getting angry dynamics that uh
Plato identify that have to do with why
people get angry now we're going to be
discussing something else this part of
the soul that he thinks is the part that
gets angry and has a very important role
or function in our you could call it the
economy of our psyche and it's clearly
connected to but not reducible to the
emotion of anger so we're going to be
looking primarily at the Republic
particularly book four but also books
two and three and nine and also at the
phaedrus just a portion of the fedrus
that has to do with the metaphor of The
Chariot and then the Timaeus where the
human being and the connection between
Body and Soul are being discussed how it
is that the Demi urge and his helpers
produce us as as beings that contain the
possibility for anger as well as many
other things and each of these each of
these dialogues is going to tell us
something important about this faculty
of thumos in relation to the soul
overall and its other parts and stresses
this is typically platonic the need for
thumos the part of us that gets angry
the part of us that desires social
status to be integrated into the rest of
the solar personality and so you know
the good life and human happiness and
full human development seem to involve
through most to some degree now we could
say well what about you know when you're
outside of the body altogether as a
disembodied Soul like in the fedris and
oh we could talk about that in a bit but
for this life right here we need this
faculty to be understood and properly
used and developed and educated and
integrated so we're going to jump around
a little bit we're going to start with
with Republic book 4 because that is
where Plato first gives us this
tripartite psychology considered in
terms of the soul and its parts and then
we'll look at the metaphor of the
Chariots here and the phaedrus then
we'll go to the
um let's call it creation account just
the part that has to do with us us human
beings in the Timaeus and the
connections between the soul and the
body and then we'll come back to
Republic book four to think about people
human beings and their roles in society
and then we'll go to Republic book two
and three think about how to properly
educate and coach and develop pneumonic
people by the way I include myself among
them and then we'll finally look at
Republic book nine and the different
kinds of pleasures and desires that are
involved
so if we look at Plato's Republic book
four from about 436 onward where parts
of the Soul are being discussed Socrates
Begins by saying do we do all of these
things that we do our functions with the
same thing or are there three things and
the functions that he singles out we
learn with one part that's the highest
rational part we get angry with another
and it's interesting that that's what he
focuses on through in the Greek it's
which can mean getting angry it can mean
a variety of different aggressive
impulses and responses we could say and
then we desire food and sex and other
stuff with the third part the appetites
which are plural and he's going to use a
form of analysis you could say that says
here's a basic assumption the same thing
doesn't do or suffer opposites in the
same way and in relation to the same
thing sort of like Aristotle's you know
law of uh non-contradiction right except
this is in terms of our human faculties
and what it is that we do so he says if
we find opposition in these then we have
a plurality we have more than one thing
doing work and so the first part that he
discusses is is what we call the
appetites or epithumia which are again
plural right there's thirst and hunger
and other appetites and he also says
that consenting and willing
um you know ethelene in Greek and boules
Thai in Greek are included in these as
well as well as the Opposites of all of
these things not being hungry not being
thirsty not Desiring sex and rejecting
and pushing things away so we've got an
appetite right now we've got these
things driving us we want to eat we want
to have sex we want to do things that
are enjoyable we want to avoid pain
but there's something in the soul he
says that forbids indulging these
appetites a different something that
Masters what is telling us go let's go
and eat let's go and and do these things
and he says this comes through the
calculations of Reason EK logistmu in
Greek that in the Soul by which it
reckons and reasons and the Greek here
is very interesting to
menai logisticon so it reasons about the
reasonable or it calculates about the
calculable it's it's engaging in this
process of saying wait a second if I do
that if I eat like a pig I'm not going
to feel good afterwards or if I go and
sleep with that person's wife then
they're going to do bad stuff to me it's
especially in ancient Greece right
so we've got two parts now we've got the
appetites down here wanting us to do
stuff we've got the rational part above
saying no no don't do that that's that's
stupid and then we have a third part
and he says this is the thumos the part
with which we feel anger toaded
and he's asking is this something
distinct from the other two you know so
we've got these affective Parts down
here that are driving us maybe thumos is
like a drive as well maybe it should be
included in those and so he he goes on
and he says
um well think about this how would we
know can it resist the appetites so he
says well I'll think about this guy
leontes who is his eyes want to look at
these dead bodies gross decaying and all
covered with wounds and he doesn't want
to do that his rational part is saying
no and he gets angry at himself at his
own desires and he says fine take a look
at them if you want to you're dirty you
know whatever this is thumos thumos can
fight against the appetites or desires
and so Plato has Socrates say when
desires constrain a person or you know
literally like use Force against them
against their reason
right
then the person abuses themselves
meaning says abusive things to
themselves Lloyd Lloyd to altone right
says abusive words to themselves and
they get angry against the part of
themselves the appetites that are going
against themselves so they
lose their temper with themselves you
could say so this means that thumos is
distinct from the other desires the
other drives the other appetites and it
can be an ally as as Plato is going to
tell us for a reason against those
appetites or desires it makes common
cause he says and then he says a few
other things that are quite interesting
so he says that when a person thinks
themselves to be in the wrong so the
Greek
hotonai when they deem themselves ADI
came to have done something wrong to
have violated some Norm the nobler they
are the less they are able to get angry
and this is the first place where he
uses a different term for getting angry
or
right rather than thumostai it's uh to
actually feel the passion of anger and
he says they're less willing to get
riled up or they they don't choose to
get
um their thumos awakened and riled up
right and but when a person thinks that
they have been wronged then they get
angry and they fight
so the words that he uses there you know
we've talked about this before the
Greeks have a wide vocabulary for
getting angry so the getting angry is
halapine which is a modality of of
getting angry and sumaki they fight with
the other person and in Noble souls he
says they will persist in this not
letting go until they achieve their
purpose or they die or Reason calls this
part of themselves back
so thumos is clearly something distinct
from the appetites and then Plato asks
as well well okay so it's not the
appetites could it be part of the
rational part of ourselves and the
answer to that is no it's not logike
it's not logistic it is something
different a third thing to use the Trope
that everybody's talking about these
days and he he points this out by making
a
an observation that you're going to see
Aristotle in the stoics and others uh
bringing up as well children don't have
reason as such the the logicon
but they certainly do have this drive
for thumos and so do animals animals get
mad right you pull the dog's tail it
turns around bites you or you know the
dogs will jockey with each other over
like who's the best dog or stuff like
that and he also brings up Homer's
Odysseus now this is very interesting
usually Plato is demythologizing the
ancient writers like Homer right in this
case though he harnesses Homer and he
says even Homer has this in mind
Odysseus smites his breast and shided
his heart and Plato has Socrates say
well this is the part in us that's
reflecting on the better and the worst
rebuking part that feels unreasoning
anger so this thumos needs to be brought
in line all right and
um in the The Republic is the theme
we're going to come back to we've talked
already a little bit about integration
thumos that middle part art is going to
be doing the work of
helping the soul to be properly arranged
the appetites have a tendency to like
get way out of control and demand too
much the rational part knows what's best
provided to the rational partisan
corrupted but the rational part can't
actually make the appetites
do what it says without the help of the
Thematic part acting as like an enforcer
an executor
so this is a very important part of
ourselves and we want to be able to
attend to it so let's go now to look at
the phaedris the metaphor of The Chariot
now this is being brought up in the
context of Eros of erotic desire the
desire to have sex with somebody else
the appreciation of their beauty or
whatever it is that we find attractive
about them and he says that the soul can
be looked at as a union of powers in a
team of winged steeds and a winged
charioteer right so
um some Futo uh you know jupo Peru
that's winged
zelgos so you know that's under the the
uh the Yoke right and so what we've got
is a charioteer and this is what our
soul is a charioteer who's in charge
it's got the Reigns right and then we've
got these two horses and with the gods
the horses are all great as a matter of
fact the gods chariots are as good as
you could possibly want
us human beings we're messed up so we
have one good horse and one bad one and
this makes it so that the job of the
Chariot here becomes quite Troublesome
something that's difficult uh Deuce
hollos something that is not fun right
something that is a pain in the rear
right we were constantly dealing with
our appetites that are getting out of
check so you know he talks about then
coming back to this discussion
the Excellence and Badness the goodness
and the Badness of these two horses the
good horse is as he says and he goes
into a long description upright and
clean limbed a lover of Glory but with
modesty and Temperance right so
teammates eraste a lover something that
desires teammates uh uh you know status
Glory but it with sofrosunes which is
um Temperance and idus shame or modesty
so this this part of ourselves this
middle part is you know pretty decent
when it's in good shape
and you don't have to whip it you just
need the word of command alone the other
horse on the other hand is a bad horse
and he says it's a real shamble of a
creature imagine like Frankenstein's
monster except in horse form
ugly hot-blooded consorting with
wanton-ness and vainglory and the
wantedness there is who brace hubrisis
right
um a companion to hubris you could say
us right this um you know making too
much of itself it thinks that it should
be running the show and it doesn't
listen it's hard to control even with a
whip and a gourd right so this horse is
real trouble so you got two horses lined
up with each other and now they're part
of the person right and when the soul of
the person this composite thing
sees their Beloved the one who they have
erotic desire towards the driver feels a
pricking of Desire the good Steed is
constrained by modesty so far so good
but the bad Steed is like I want to
screw I want to have sex with that
person I don't care what they think they
are attractive I want to force myself on
them and it tries to LEAP as he says on
to the loved one and so they struggle
not the loved one and the horse but
rather within the the person they
struggle and the uh bad horse is
indignant and the word that's being used
there's another anger word on
agnocode over being forced into a bad
action
um but then you know they kind of give
in to the bad horse but when they get
close the charioteer pulls on the reins
and and the horses fall back the good
one is willing and unresistant the bad
one against his will because he's not
getting what he wants and the good horse
is motivated by once again shame ice
khunes and by it's translated as horror
but it could be translated as
the bad horse though interestingly
breaks into angry abuse is how it's
translated
and it really is the word for anger orge
and it says a Lloyd
right which means to abuse with words uh
it abuses the other horse it abuses The
Chariot here so we've got an interesting
Dynamic here anger is being felt by the
appetites themselves not just in the
Thematic part of the soul and this
happens over and over again until
eventually either the evil horse is
broken which is the way they they talk
about it there
um you know broken of their hubris or
the person gives into the bad parts
right and he talks about the lover and
the Beloved laying next to each other
and the parts of their soul
communicating with each other so the
charioteer communicates with the
charioteer the good horse with a good
horse the bad horse with the bad horse
and you know what's what's involved here
the possibility which will not be
realized for most human beings most
likely
of subjecting the power of evil in your
soul and liberating the power of good
developing self-mastery inward peace
happiness the philosophical life these
are all things that Socrates is talking
about so now we've got two pictures of
the Soul as tripartite
and they kind of complement each other
later platonists tended to harmonize
these points of view with each other
there are some tensions there though I
think right because
um you know at no point is the good
Steed called thumos we just have to read
that in and we see that the bad horse
which is the appetites presumably
can get angry and be abusive in the same
way that in the Republic
the middle part of the Soul would abuse
the person namely the appetites that
were doing bad stuff so before we go on
to the Timaeus any questions comments
confusions clarifications that are
needed at this point we'll give it just
a minute and see whether there's
anything that we need to delve into
further at this point with the phaedrus
and this little bit of the Republic
so
Mark says always find the charioteer
metaphor interesting
interesting it's also kind of puzzling
it's it's funny too because I had some
people recently who were wanting to talk
about
um ancient philosophy and the soul and
anger and that was their main point of
reference was the phaedrus not the
Republic where I think you get a much
Fuller treatment which you really need
in order to be able to make sense of
what's happening in the fade risks right
so that's a good point well let's go on
to the Timaeus so in the Timaeus now
this is a later dialogue right and it's
about like the generation the production
the poiesis of the entire universe
according to certain patterns
and
um human beings are part of the things
that are being produced and there's two
different discussions about the human
body and the soul and their parts and
they're they're really complementary to
each other one is earlier on in in 69
and 70 the other is almost at the very
end of the dialogue in 89 to 91. so
in the first one
um the Divine creates all the elements
and the universe and proportions and
then turns things over to their
offspring to create mortal things like
you and me US human beings and animals
and plants and all that sort of stuff so
with human beings they
um take the immortal principle of the
Soul as he calls it and then they make a
body a mortal body to be the vehicle as
we translate it of the Soul now the word
used there for vehicle
chariot
right so there's there's kind of a
connection to the phaedrus isn't there
um so the you know they created the the
body to be a vehicle to the soul and
then they create another kind of Soul
alote uh a different kind of Soul
that's mortal so we've got an immortal
Soul that's what we are right but then
we also have a mortal soul and then we
have a body and the Mortal Soul as he
says is subject to the passions and it's
very interesting here because what
passions does he talk about so Pleasure
and Pain very common in in Plato's
discussions right rashness and fear or
confidence and fear
and then he says anger hard to be
appeased to moan thumos
[Music]
a a hard to placate kind of anger and
then he says that it's mingled with
irrational sense I stasis and with all
daring love and again sort of a
reference back to the phaedrus isn't it
and so then these helpers of the God not
wanting to corrupt the Divine Soul they
give the Mortal nature a home below the
neck so our head is where the immortal
part of the soul the best part of the
Soul resides and then everything else is
happening in our chest and our belly and
our genitals and he talks about our neck
as being like an isthmus right meaning
that it's it's a a place between two
continents so the Superior part of the
irrational Soul the thumos goes into the
chest closer to the Head this he says is
the part that has courage Andrea right
the virtue of courage and anger thumu
and that likes to compete with people
it's Philo Nikon meaning it it uh craves
or desires Victory it craves or desires
winning and it's placed where it is
right here so it can be obedient to the
rule of reason and it can join with it
in controlling the appetites when they
won't obey as they should same sort of
model as we've just seen in the Republic
and the phaedrus right the Thematic part
the part that gets angry is it's got a
job
so
a little bit later on towards the end of
the dialogue he talks about
purifying and reuniting the body
and he says that there's different ways
of doing this the the third best way is
the treatment of Physicians right and
why because that's moving Parts uh by
external agency so you know the the
doctor gives you drugs or
recommendations about what to eat or you
know cuts off
diseased limbs or things like that right
and then there's Motions like sailing
where we're moving the body and doing
stuff with it and you know that's okay
that's that's movement caused by others
but the best mode of working on the body
is gymnastics exercise exercises that we
choose to do ourselves it's self
movement which is something very
important for the the soul uh but also
for the body
um the soul moves the body and thereby
does things and he says that each part
of the Soul has its own motions
when they're not exercised they get weak
so if we you know if we don't exercise
our appetites
um you know from a platonic perspective
that might be kind of a good thing so
long as we don't get to the point where
we don't want to eat it all or drink at
all but you know we can go without sex
and Plato would probably say
um but you know we also have our fumotic
part and our rational part and if we
don't exercise our rational part then we
become or remain stupid and if we don't
exercise our themodic part that part
can't do its job it can't protect us
from external threats it can't
administer Justice it can't
um
you know work against the appetites uh
at the bidding of reason so this is
quite important
so we need to take care he says that the
movements of the different parts are in
the right proportion and the Greek word
there is sumetrus right
in in Harmony in a measured way in
relation to each other
so he says that when a person is
occupied with appetites epithomias and
ambition philonechias and trying to
satisfy them then you know their
thoughts are mortal so if if we're
mainly concerned with the things of the
lower appetites or our thermos then you
know that's okay but that's going to
make us much more bodily you could think
about this in terms of the Fado as well
right
so that's quite important but if we
focus on the higher part and this is
very important not just its activities
but its desires its own desires its own
Pleasures its own activities then our
thoughts are Immortal and divine and so
there's you know kind of a
proportionality here Plato is not saying
you know get rid of your body it's just
garbage get rid of your appetites your
thumos just be rationality he actually
tells us we need to give each part its
characteristic you could translate it as
food or nourishment therapea right
um and or trophos actually uh is is the
word being used there and it's it's
right motions it's right activities
right so this is where the Timaeus
basically ends giving us some additional
ideas about how the body and soul are
connected and what we want to be do
doing with these different parts so let
me take some of these these other points
that are coming up thinking about the
issue of thermos and how it might relate
to the two forces I think there are two
categories of things you could get angry
at in yourself doing something you
shouldn't have doing not doing something
you should have not saying that's its
meaning just a thought yeah I mean that
that's that's quite right so we get
angry at ourselves and notice the should
there right so there's some sort of Norm
going on there's things that we ought to
do things that we shouldn't do when we
do the things we shouldn't do why did we
do them well we listened to the
appetites or we let our thermos get out
out of check and we like hit somebody
when we shouldn't have or we were
abusive to them verbally right and then
there's things that we don't do and we
kick ourselves for that later so that's
a good point
Mark also says do you think that the
location of the thumos in the chest
leads to a physiological connection for
example rapid heart rate Breathing
heavily a lump in the throat as you
might experience when angry
yeah I mean I feel my anger in my chest
what the Greeks called the thorax right
um
I don't know that everybody does like
some people they say that they feel it
more in their stomach you know like it
leads to
um problems with digestion and it's
interesting because there is another
discussion in in the Tomas that I didn't
bring up where he talks about the liver
and typically the liver in a lot of
other thinkers
is associated with anger because it
produces holos bile right and
melancholos is black bile the word that
we get Melancholy from and the
melancholic person is choleric right uh
liable to get angry with people
um they're not just like sad and you
know lying around all the time or
anything like that so
um it's interesting that that the liver
is not connected with anger in that
dialogue whereas it is for so many
others as well
all right let's talk about Republic book
four so when we come back to it we've
talked about the individual person now
you know what is Republic book 4 about
it is about the city and about different
kinds of people who
um have to do different jobs so some
people are supposed to be in charge
running the city the administrators or
as he calls them the Guardians and then
you know at the bottom not really at the
bottom they're just not given power
right they they actually have a much
Freer life they get to like do their
thing and accumulate money and have
possessions whereas the Guardians don't
are the craftspeople and the crafts
people do all the other kinds of stuff
and they're presumably you know
motivated more by their appetites and
then we have this other group The
auxiliaries the Lesser Guardians who you
know would correspond to the Army to
Firefighters Police emergency people the
people that Rush towards danger instead
of running away from it and so you know
Plato has Socrates say the good city in
the full sense of the word it will need
to have certain virtues
it needs to be wise it needs to be
courageous it needs to be temperate and
it needs to be just and what are these
going to look like in the city and then
what will it look like in its citizens
and where are we going to find these
various aspects of it so he says well
you know in the Guardians we have the
wisdom going on in the crafts people and
actually and everybody everybody needs
Temperance he says
but where are we going to find
courage
well we have to look at the part of the
city that defends the city and wages war
on its behalf or at literally engages in
strategy on its behalf so he asked well
what does courage look like in these
people
and it's very interesting that instead
of saying it's a kind of knowledge
itself
or it's just a habit he calls it a
preservation a soteria and so soter
means salvation but it also means like
retaining something so you you have
something that you've been given and you
retain it you preserve it so what do you
preserve you preserve a conviction a
doks say right
um the doke say not just in terms of
like an appearance or opinion or
reputation
but adults say a conviction of the law
that was created by education about what
is actually to be feared so we do have a
cognitive component to courage right it
is knowing what you should fear but
there's all of this other stuff involved
with it that has to do with the part of
ourselves that you know is is thematic
so the courageous person he's got this
this great uh metaphor the courageous
person is going to preserve this
knowledge and practical knowledge in
pains and Pleasures in desires and fears
so when being moved by the appetites
right
and he says that there's an analogy here
between education and dying wool
um the forms of educating the Soul music
and gymnastics that we're going to talk
about in a bit they die the soul with
the right convictions these laws or
Norms the no more and they resist being
washed out by passions of pain and fear
or desire
so the people who are going to be doing
the fighting going to be doing the
protection they not only protect the
city they not only save the city they
have to save something within themselves
that has to do with dealing with what is
actually scary in not just dealing with
fear but dealing with desire dealing
with pleasure dealing with pain a
independence from a Detachment from
those sorts of passions not necessarily
the person not feeling them but not
allowing those to be determinative
so we can ask at this point you know
what does this have to do with anger and
you know for understanding that we have
to go back to book two in the Republic
where he talks about the Guardians and
he says that you know in general
Guardians need to be like Watchdogs and
here he's talking about both the the
higher and the lower Guardians they need
to be Keen in perception quick to pursue
strong to fight they need to be
courageous and here's where we come back
to the thumos
they can't be this unless they are
high-spirited is how it's translated or
thematic fumo ades so thumos 80s of the
kind of you know soul of the kind of
being that has this strong fumotic angry
passionate element in it
and he says there's a danger involved in
this so this is where anger comes in
right there's a danger of these people
being Savage Agri aggressive to each
other and to their fellow citizens and
he says what we need is for them to be
gentle or good-tempered prowse to their
familiars Oikos the people who are of
their household of their city but harsh
hadapus to the enemies so halepus can be
angry towards their enemies they need to
be not angry towards
the people that they're supposed to
protect they need to be angry or
aggressive towards the people that they
have to protect them against
and he says there seems to be an
opposition between being great-spirited
and being gentle uh gentle being proud
and uh great-spirited being Megalo
thumon right having great thumos so you
know people who are
fit for command people who are willing
to fight people who are willing to Brave
Danger
it can be more of a challenge for them
to control their anger to be nice to
other people and so uh Plato is going to
say it seems that being gentle and High
Spirit are are actually opposed to each
other anantia in Greek right opposites
to each other fumo a day and praia and
he says maybe this is by nature foosis
so that's what's going on in book two
and the remedy for this is going to show
up in book three
so there's this return to considering
the education of the youth now this is
after we get through like let's kick the
poets out you know they tell
stories they're bad you know all these
sorts of problems so he wants to think
about well how should we educate young
people
specifically young people who are going
to be protecting the society
so we need music which is poetry and
other content he talks about like you
can do this through weaving tapestries
this is all memetic artwork right and
then gymnastics or physical education
and he says that the key here is to
Foster the virtues through imitation and
habituation and to wean people away from
the vices they might otherwise fall into
and there's a lot of people who at that
time are saying well listen you got the
soul you got the body gymnastics is just
for the body
but uh music is for the soul so you got
two different ways of dealing with
things and Plato says no no it's not
quite so simple both music and
gymnastics can be done in order to deal
with this spirited part of your nature
prostateos so it's not just music for
the soul and gymnastics or the body if
you want a well developed person in
terms of this thematic part you really
have to focus on both and he says that
there's problems with people who devote
themselves just to one or to the other
so we can either have savagery and
harshness on the one hand agrio tatos to
Kai scleros uh you know sclerosis is
like being a scumbag essentially right
so think about a tough guy a movie tough
guy right who comes in and wants to
cause trouble all the time well if you
only focus on the body that's what you
end up with but if you only focus on
music well then you are making the
person to you know Peaceable
and weak or soft right and that's not
good
so we need a little bit of both
the savagery part is derived from being
Thermo Andis being a thematic person
which if rightly trained becomes courage
but if over strained if it done
exclusively gets hard and harsh so think
about these people who go to the gym and
take steroids and they're all about
being tough guys right
they're failures from a platonic
perspective right because they're only
attending to one part of their their
person
he says that the high-spirited person
who doesn't do gymnastics but has just
music and too much of it the Thematic
part gets weakened remember back to the
tomatoes we need to have the right kind
of nourishment and exercise for our
different parts of our soul music is not
enough and so this kind of person gets
irascible and choleric they're they're
kind of peevish you know they break out
and stuff and so he says that the
high-spirited person who doesn't have
engagement with music or philosophy gets
really fit and prideful and more
high-spirited and confident and brave
but they become a mythologist a term
that comes up in the Fado as well a
hater of argument hater of discourse and
they don't use persuasion but just force
so we really need to focus on both of
these aspects both of these ways of
modifying not just the body but also the
human soul and we need to do this
especially with those who are going to
be tasked with using that thematic part
of their soul to protect Society to
protect the city to
help other people you know firemen are
another example so here's a good
question from Mark
we did Nietzsche's first essay from the
genealogy of morals in a discussion
group today what you're saying about the
guardian class and thumos makes me think
of some of the things he says about the
nightly aristocratic class funny given
what nature writes about Plato is there
a homeric link here yeah I mean
Nietzsche is
Nature's View
is not
always against Plato he actually thinks
that Plato
um
went wrong because he followed Socrates
right and Socrates is the real problem
Socrates and his sidekick euripides who
is already in the the birth of tragedy
who are
um you know kind of turning against the
heroic homeric Greek uh way of of
looking at things and as well as the
earlier tragedy where you have this this
synthesis of the apollonian dionysian
the socratic is something different than
both of those which replaces those and
you know uh Plato Nietzsche says in the
birth of tragedy that Plato's dialogues
are a new kind of
literary genre produced out of the
Shipwreck of tragedy and kind of
cobbling together all the different
pieces into something quite new now he
does you know say that Plato is wrong
about you know the body of the soul and
that you know Christianity is platonism
for the masses that that's all true
um and you could look at you know
Plato's and Socrates ethics in
significant part
as being either a rejection of or a
harnessing of what Nietzsche is calling
the you know primary morality of those
the strong uh defining themselves as
good uh rivaling with each other and
then defining the the commoners as as
weak now it's a little bit more
complicated because you have the figure
of the priest who comes out of the
aristocratic class and there's other
values being built in there but we'll
put that aside for just a moment
um yeah you could you could look at what
Nietzsche is doing in uh the genealogy
and birth of tragedy and also I would
say and Beyond Good and Evil and and
thus folksarathustra as a rejection of
Plato's proposal that what we ought to
do is is have these different parts of
the Soul three main parts and you know
reasons should call the shots thumos
should enforce it and the appetites
should obey and be indulged to a certain
extent
now Nietzsche is rejecting that on two
two counts one of them is that Nietzsche
thinks that this thematic part
I mean that's
like the will the power isn't it so
maybe we should grow that maybe we
shouldn't keep it within bounds and
subordinate it to our rational part
um the other thing is that Nietzsche
thinks that the human being
you know and Plato does think this is
well most of us human beings are messed
up uh unharmonious parts of our souls
right Nietzsche thinks that trying to
harmonize your soul is a mistake that
it's not going to happen the virtues
fight against each other he says right
so you're never going to really pull
that off Plato is holding out that as a
prospect for us so in a sense you could
say they have a similar starting point
of disorganization within the soul and
conflict within the soul nature thinks
you're never going to get fully away
from that you can just have certain
drives dominating others Plato thinks
you can have a harmonious Arrangement
right so that's that's an important set
of distinctions there uh Mark says to me
gymnastics and music are good types of
Education they both involve discipline
and habituation and these are needed to
cultivate a healthy thumos how do you
think these could be re-envisioned in
contemporary education okay so that's a
that's a big and great question that I
don't think I'll have a complete answer
to
um so obviously
music including what we call music today
and
narrative it's not just poetry but it's
like narrative Arts so film TV
um poetry
um actual writing I mean Plato also
brings up tapestries that depict things
so you know paintings and sculptures and
stuff like that we call this the world
of culture
um he talks about mimesis and this is
something that I I thought I might get
to but might not you know like in book
10 there's this long discussion of
mimesis and you know some suggestions
that the emotions or the passions can be
uh fostered and educated through
um memetic forms so you know when we
think about the music that we listen to
or the television shows that we watch
um it's you know it's not like there's a
one-to-one connection between seeing
people beat other people up and then
going out there and being like this is
my thumos you know
but there there is like you point out a
habituation that takes place right so we
need the right kind of models we don't
want everything to be sugar and spice
and everything nice right because we do
in fact need to have our thumos
developed and properly
directed so we can't just like make
everybody nice to each other and have
properly developed thumos now physical
training I think can also figure into
this and you can think about like weight
lifting and the ways in which people do
it right they can do it in ways that are
kind of fostering this goofy
version of masculinity that they have or
they can do it in a way that's more in
tuned with how Plato thinks thermos
needs to be developed so that
you have the strength and the discipline
and the endurance that's needed for
accomplishing things during difficulty
right and so anger could be a part of
that but it's going to have to be
rightly directed right you don't want
some Jim bro who's like in roid rages
all the time that's that's way at the
end of the extreme that Plato would say
that's that's bad that's Agri oil right
that's that's kind of funny because
agrio and Agro that we use sometimes to
talk about aggressivity in people
similar sounding aren't they right so
that's that's quite important uh Mark
says part of why Plato likes to
antagonize The Poets poetry and the
sense of media that the public engages
can influence a person's through most if
they're not able to resist it yeah and I
would not just say it can it does by the
time that we start thinking about this
stuff in the kind of societies that
we're in where
um because of the internet and you know
Global Communications
our lives are saturated not just with
images and not just with words but with
narratives right
we we are probably screwed up by the
time that we're thinking about this
we've got all sorts of bad messages you
know about what it is to be a properly
themodic person I mean we don't even use
that term right we just talk about like
what does it mean to be a man or what
does it mean to be a tough guy or what
does it mean to be courageous right and
we're all over the map when it comes to
Courageous right we call all sorts of
people Brave who aren't brave because
they did this one thing over here we we
Overlook people who aren't so yeah this
is this is a very very significant issue
and this is a good segue into the last
thing that I was going to bring up which
is in book nine so
book nine comes after a discussion about
how cities go bad in book eight right
and then it leads to the Tyrant and
there's some discussion about well is
the Tyrant a happy person or an unhappy
person but then we get a discussion of
the three kinds of people again
and interestingly before that there's
this little side discussion about good
dreams and Plato suggests that we should
tame the passionate part of ourselves
and not go to sleep in Anger after a
quarrel why because we're going to have
all sorts of quarrelsome dreams right
we're going to still be working out our
conflicts in our dreams so we don't want
to do that and then a little bit later
he's going to talk about the three kinds
of people in three parts of the soul and
he's going to say you got some people as
we've remarked already who are much more
uh intellectual much more rational it's
not that they don't have a thematic part
or a uh the appetites but they're not
they're primarily driven by the desire
to learn the desire to think about
things the desire to manage things
um
but then there's people who are in fact
driven by their appetites and you know
the craftspeople they want to get drunk
they want to screw they want to have
money they want to have a good time
right this is the life of pleasure and
avoiding pain and the life that has to
be oriented towards doing the things you
need to do in order to get the stuff
that you want and then we've got the
people who are thematic the people who
are driven uh by you know this desire to
protect but also a desire to win a
desire to have social status or honor
right a desire to succeed and he says
you got these three different kinds of
people and each of them each of their
parts of the Soul has their specific
kinds of pleasure like you know what is
it the intellectual the rational person
takes pleasure in thinking about stuff
learning about stuff what is it the
person who's driven by their desires and
what do the desires take pleasure in
getting what they want want drinking
eating having sex laying in the sun you
know watching TV what is it that the
Thematic person wants
well he tells us it's focused on Victory
Nikkei and honor teammate and so they
not only have their kinds of Pleasures
they have their kinds of desires their
orientations their affective
orientations and different ways in which
they control things now reason controls
by telling us what to do thumos controls
by like you know it's activity the
appetite's controlled by making us
pursue their their objects
and
he tells us that we could have a couple
different ways of being a spirited
person the love of honor is not really
motivated as such by learning except as
it leads to honor so you know you could
be a philosopher in a graduate program
this would describe me particularly
during my nietzschean phase uh who is
interested in learning and enjoys it
right but interested in learning so you
can debate with other people and be the
big shot who knows more who competes and
wins right
not a very good way to do things well
often a very frustrating way it leads
into a lot of zero-sum situations uh but
that is the way a lot of people who are
driven by Honor are motivated and they
can despise the pleasures of the
appetites you know they are interested
in their self-image their interest in
their ranking they're not so much
interested in getting drunk or high or
having sex or all these other things
except perhaps insofar as it conduces to
honor right so if you beat people in a
drinking contest that could be thematic
rather than just being driven by
appetites right if you compete with how
many sexual partners you can have or the
great reviews that your partners give
you or something like that that could be
being themotic and competing right and
you could do this for all sorts of other
things like accumulation of wealth might
be thematic for some people and pleasure
driven for other other people now one of
the things that he tells us in book nine
is that the person who's driven by their
appetites and the person who's driven by
thumos
is not really well equipped to judge
between the three kinds of motivations
and their Pleasures who is the person
who is motivated by intellect reasoning
by that higher part of ourselves
um they are the only one who can really
do a good judgment of all three of these
the other people think that they can't
judge rightly but they're not able to
which means that there's a limitation to
the Thematic person the person who gets
angry a lot the person who may be
courageous but is also driven by a
desire to conquer to succeed to beat
other people right
so he tells us that the person who
indulges and satisfies the spirited part
is going to be problematic why because
they have this desire for Honor which
can turn into Envy Envy is a big problem
for the ancient Greeks
they have a love of victory that can
turn into violence
and by indulging themselves in Anger
itself they can become more and more
prone to anger to ill-temper to being
irascible and why does this happen
because they're not listening to this
rational part which is weaker and not
being given it's it's proper share now
you know to bring up Nietzsche nature
would say that's great that's exactly
how you want to be Plato would say no no
that's not how you want to be you want
to be listening to and developing this
rational part no matter how strong your
themodic part is it's not supposed to be
running the show it's got a vital role
to perform it should be in you know work
worked out exercised educated uh
tempered in the right way it's really
important don't leave it out because you
need it to help you know against the
appetites and against external threats
but it's got to be subject to the higher
part this is Plato's refrain over and
over and over again so we can see
um how important anger and the part that
gets angry actually is in the platonic
perspective and this is going to be
something that is going to be
characteristic not just of Plato but
also of those who follow in his
footsteps so we can talk about middle
platonism later on we could talk about
neoplatonic philosophy and we can talk
about how it feeds into you know not
just Pagan neoplatonism but Christian
and Jewish neoplatonism a lot of this is
going to be a recognition that thumos
has its legitimate place and then the
question will be how do you go beyond
Plato and just saying music and
gymnastics in educating it but this is
where we'll leave off in terms of
studying Plato we so we've looked at
Plato's dialogues that have to do with
you know how anger arises what produces
it now we've looked at you know the
function of anger for Plato and uh we'll
take a let's take a few more questions
and do some discussion so from what I
understand I've played out all
philosopher kings are Guardians not all
Guardians are philosopher Kings
honor would seem to be common to both as
both would want to tame their thumos do
you think honor is needed for
psychological well-being what do you
think honorable would mean today so that
that's a great set of questions
um when I'm talking to my students who
are not philosophy Majors for the most
part and our undergraduates I have to
like put this into contemporary terms
that are a little bit easier to
understand than honor honor has kind of
an archaic you know where you violated
my honor I shall duel you at dawn sort
of sort of feeling to it right
and I think we can frame it in terms of
a constellation of other Concepts like
respect
or social status right those are things
you get from other people
and are acknowledged by other people
um we could also talk about self-esteem
which is more oriented towards what
you're giving yourself you honor
yourself right
um
and you know we could talk about it
feeding off into other things that like
you know Plato and the other people
um in his tradition would consider bad
like like Fame for example you know Fame
is very empty we nowadays call it
celebrity but that that could be honor
as well
so um that is that is important and do
you think honor is needed for
psychological well-being
some measure of it is
but it really depends on what we're
being honored for and who we're being
honored by
if we are being honored by people who we
think are actually bad people that's
probably a sign that something is going
wrong right and maybe we shouldn't be
honored by them maybe they we maybe we
want them to not like us
um if we're being honored
um you know for things that are really
valuable
that we genuinely possess because
sometimes we get honored for stuff that
we don't have and we're like oh you know
uh you shouldn't be saying all those
great things about me because I'm not so
great
um
that yeah so being honored for what is
valuable about ourselves and I think
there's a lot of people there's a little
bit of a tangent
I think there's a lot of people in our
society who are at risk of not
giving themselves honor
for
things that they should
they think well I'm doing things but
they're not very good so you know for
example
I'm teaching in this place but I'm not
you know a full Professor or students
aren't like you know knocking down the
door for my classes or sometimes the
students fall asleep or you know I'm not
teaching in a famous place or something
like that right it's easy to get down on
yourself and say oh the stuff I'm doing
isn't really that good but what you're
doing is good insofar as it's it's you
know something that you're doing if
you're educating somebody and you're
helping them even if you're not helping
them all the way to understanding every
single thing about Plato you are giving
them something that they can choose to
use just like if you you know let's say
you're doing athletic training and
somebody comes in and there are 400
pounds and they're like super out of
shape and wheezing as they come up the
the stairs and you work with them for a
couple months and they drop 60 pounds
they're still 340 pounds but they're in
better shape right that is an
achievement that is a success and I
think a lot of times
we we don't
give ourselves
the right kind of honor and you know
this is very important in terms of
recognition uh Mark says I like to think
of Honor in terms of the red Tian spaces
of appearances honor and dishonor is an
important way in how we're evaluated by
our peers other citizens and political
life it is a way of recognizing as a
person Excellence uh yeah I mean or at
least the appearance of Excellence right
because again many people are honored
who don't deserve it at all and many
people are not honored who do deserve it
and it could be political it could be
cultural it could be educational it
could be in all these different
institutional areas of life and I think
there's platonic stuff
is applicable not just in terms of like
you know the soul and the city but also
the soul and the family the soul and the
marketplace the soul and the workplace
the soul and the university we could go
on and on and on uh about that so
yeah now you bring up magnet magnanimity
a great soldness
something that Plato doesn't talk about
all that often
um
you know he does mention it as an
example of a virtue in the Mino although
it's Mino who brings it up
and that's more of a thing that I would
say Aristotle and the stoics develop
discussions of and you know later
platonists do as well
um but yeah magnanimity involving
receiving the honor that you do or
demanding as Aristotle will say the
honor that you're due it's interesting
too because this is a bit of a side note
the magnanimous person in Aristotle is
liable to make other people angry
because to be magnanimous involves
catafronesis despising showing contempt
to things that are beneath you and if
other people take those things seriously
they might get angry at you because they
think that you're disrespecting them
because you don't care about their their
stuff right so like if people are super
super into football
and you're like I don't care which team
wins or loses it's just and you and you
say That's Just Sports ball you know I'm
a serious person I look at at stuff that
really matters
well they're gonna get ticked off right
because because maybe you actually are
above it but you don't have to rub their
nose in it now the last thing I'll say
about this too is that
I think that you know one of the terms
that that
um Hegel uses and we can talk about
other philosophers being in a tradition
talking about this so you know Hobbs
fits it figures into this Hume does Adam
Smith all the way up to like Renee
Gerard is
[Music]
um
recognition or acknowledgment what Hagel
calls anir Cannon
this is very important this is something
that we we do uh want to have something
we desire from other people and when we
force the recognition it doesn't really
work or if the recognition is over stuff
that we actually think is kind of BS you
know we're not getting the recognition
we want
um oh here's a very interesting question
since we're moving on from Plato what of
Plato's discussions of anger has been
most significant to you in terms of
helping you wrestle with your own
problems with anger
well I think that recognition that
you know however we want to think about
it the personality the soul the psyche
we don't necessarily have to have a a
dualist substance perspective on this
but I would say that you know being able
to recognize myself
as somebody who is gifted with
intellectual capacities but was very
often driven by thumos by this desire
to beat out other people to be on top to
attain recognition and honor and to get
you know to be angry and to be concerned
with Justice and stuff like that
recognizing that my fumos was out of
whack in part because it wasn't
adequately Guided by rationality that
was very helpful for me
um and it didn't like change everything
all at once
but
it made me I you know I had I had a lot
of anger
um I could say and if we're thinking in
platonic anthropology or psychology my
themodic part was way too overgrown and
had been indulged far too much
um so it needed to be pruned back a bit
and you know gotten into better shape
instead of being a big bulky weight
lifter it needed to be a more you know
thin endurance uh oriented
uh you know
person who could March and fight and
stuff like that so you know it'd be
interested to see what what that Journey
looks like for other people if other
people have been helped by reading Plato
and thinking about these matters I mean
it's kind of a revelation for me reading
it uh especially in graduate school and
like taking it seriously when I was
actually getting interested in
philosophy and and anger so that's that
that is a great question Mark says oh
this is interesting I was somebody with
an atrophied fubos Plato helped me
rehabilitate it yeah so you could be and
I think this happens to a lot of people
especially if you've been like forced
into one down positions in relation to
other people through trauma or abuse or
even neglect or
um you know all sorts of other things
that could happen to a person sometimes
people don't have
that
thematic part of themselves adequately
developed where it could do its job and
you know I mean what is it doing when it
does its job it's controlling the
appetites but it's also pushing back
against people who are going to take
advantage of us and it's helping us to
protect those who we should protect and
say no to people proposing bad things
and it helps us to ask for the things
that we do deserve right
um
so the thumos you know it does need to
be developed whatever Walk of Life we're
going to be in even if we were going to
be like one of the platonic Guardians
they need to do most too right they got
to be able to
make difficult decisions and stick with
them and that's not all just a matter of
rationality there's there's some
some other aspects involved in that so
well that is a good place I think to
wrap up
some excellent uh questions hopefully
the presentation is clear enough for
anybody who's going to be watching this
later
um again you know Focus was on Republic
primarily book four but also books two
and three and book nine and then on
portions of the phaedris and portions of
the tomatoes so next time we're actually
I think if I remember the lineup we're
going to be shifting gears a little bit
and going back into Antiquity and
looking at Homer uh specifically The
Iliad lots and lots of anger I mean the
whole thing begins with anger and so we
will start from there